je fais je fais je fais
[Applaudissements]
je suis dallas et je suis marié à matt je suis
matt et je suis marié à cassie je suis
cassie et je suis marié à matt et je suis
aussi marié à dallas  je suis aussi marié
à cassie je suis aussi marié à dallas et
nous sommes tous les deux mariés à matthew
[Musique]
mais nos pouvoirs combinés nous sommes mariés
et par nos pouvoirs combinés nous sommes tous les trois
mariés
[Musique]
étranger
c'est mon bureau et vous pouvez le dire parce
qu'il y a tellement de photos de doute
qu'il y a beaucoup de photos de ça mais
il y a tellement de photos de dallas là
-bas et puis c'est là que matt travaille
habituellement il y a rosie c'est notre bébé
donc c'est notre salon  ouais euh
c'est un peu comme une
ambiance d'étude botanique en cours
et nous avons notre autel pour euh notre sanctuaire
puis il y a une photo de notre mariage
c'était juste après notre mariage à
Dallas et j'ai commencé à sortir ensemble quand nous étions
elle avait 17 ans et j'étais  16. nous voulions
nous marier dès notre premier rendez-vous ouais je
pense que lors de notre premier rendez-vous, nous avons parlé de
notre mariage  ing nous l'avons fait et nous avions tout ce
plan
que nous allions nous marier quand
nous avions 20 ans
, puis Matt est arrivé
et donc évidemment cela a changé ce
changement
[Music] à
travers un spin ouais
c'est intéressant pour moi que vous ayez
un tel i  devinez une
relation non traditionnelle mais vous vouliez garder
certains éléments traditionnels ouais la
tradition est importante pour nous je dirais que
certains gardent à la retraite
comme si nos pères ne nous accompagnaient pas
dans l'allée non euh parce qu'il n'y avait
pas d'homme me donnant  un autre homme non
je suis heureux tu es heureux c'est bien
très heureux les gens n'arrêtent pas de me demander comment va la
vie de marie je suis genre c'est super mec
c'est super
avec quelqu'un
pour le reste de ta vie comme tu vas de l'
avant et toi tu te mets devant
tout le monde et tu leur dis
combien tu les aimes pour que tu
puisses t'engager
[Musique]
quand je suis avec toi
mon âme
est vivante
[Musique]
je ressens
tant de couleurs
[Musique]
quand  tu étais assis là-bas en
train de regarder la vidéo
j'aimais te regarder regarder la vidéo
non pas parce que tu pleurais parce que
ce sont vous savez
que nos deux sens des parents se sont bien passés depuis
et ils seraient si heureux
qu'ils auraient été ravis à mort
et ils  n'auraient pas compris qu'ils
auraient compris mais ils ne s'en seraient
pas souciés parce que tant que Cassie était
heureuse c'est ce qui aurait été
important ouais même si tu es ouvert
à ça c'est comme comment ça marche donc
devenir si proche  avec eux et
regardez-les comme ensemble vous apprenez comme
wow la chimie est assez incroyable est-
ce que je connais trois autres personnes qui se
connectent comme ces trois deux non je
ne sais pas non je ne connais même pas des couples
qui se connectent comme ces trois très bien
nous le
faisons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait un peu comme oh mais
vous savez l'engagement ne peut pas vraiment être
val vous savez comme légal et contraignant et
il y a une tristesse à cela  parce que
pourquoi pas
pourquoi ils sont si amoureux et ils sont si
incroyables ensemble
pourquoi ça ne peut pas être
mais peut-être qu'un jour comme tu le sais peut-être
un jour ça le fera et j'espère que mais ils
étaient comme ça n'a pas d'importance nous  Je veux
recréer
notre amour et j'étais comme si vous saviez ce
que nous allions être là et nous
allions et nous allions les soutenir 100
nous étions tellement excités
lors des cérémonies
que diriez-vous sont les principales
idées fausses que les gens ont  à propos de toi
que nous ne nous connaissons pas ouais
dallas et je ne sais rien l'un de l'
autre et c'est euh
il a deux femmes mais nous ne savons pas ouais
il vit une double vie ouais il
déconne ouais j'ai un côté  morceau
ou peu importe ouais c'est la première chose que l'
on me demande habituellement est est-ce qu'ils
se connaissent et c'est comme ouais ouais je suis
comme bien tu sais ouais tu sais on plaisante
à ce sujet comme ça on essaie de le garder on
peut essayer de garder  une certaine légèreté autour de ça,
mais honnêtement, c'est un peu sexiste de
supposer que nous sommes dans un po
relation lygame une relation polygame
met tout le pouvoir sur mat et
dit regarde c'est un peu comme une
supposition que
nous sommes juste assis à attendre que
mat nous dise que nous allons avoir une
relation avec lui et
il va avoir  deux femmes et nous sommes
comme pour le trajet mais vraiment je veux dire
dallas et j'étais là en premier si
quoi que ce soit euh
matt est notre mari soeur ouais
incroyable tu es tu es un petit joli
petit ami ouais
et c'est notre lit où  nous dormons tous les trois
même si
nous ne sommes pas vraiment en forme, mais nous ne pouvons pas essayer
de nous adapter, nous ne pouvons pas mettre un lit king-size
dans notre petite chambre, alors faites-le, nous
devons juste être d'accord avec ça parce que
si  nous mettons un lit king-size alors nous ne pouvons pas
entrer dans nos vêtements ce serait la
chambre
et le seigneur sait que nous avons besoin d'un placard avec
nous tous nous avons trois personnes deux placards
donc nous gardons très chaud la nuit oui
en hiver  on a pas du tout besoin
de chauffer la nuit ouais non non
mais en somme  mer temps en été, il est
diffusé sur 68 arizona 68.
il fait chaud oui la deuxième plus grande
idée fausse est que c'est une grande
fête de monstres sexuels ouais c'était juste comme le
sexe sexe sexe tout le temps trios
orgies et euh et puis certains ouais c'est
ce que les gens pensent  notre vie sexuelle est je
dirais
comme normalement normale stupide normale ouais
je dirais que nous avons des relations sexuelles
environ une fois par semaine euh chacun de nous a
probablement tous des relations sexuelles une fois par semaine,
que ce soit tous les trois ensemble
ou
un séparé de nous ou deux de nous  ensemble
et l'un de nous n'étant pas impliqué ouais,
je pense que c'est dans des occasions plus rares
que nous avons tous les trois des relations sexuelles
ensemble simplement parce que trois dynamiques sont
toutes naturellement activées en même temps,
c'est difficile à réaliser et nous ne
voulons pas être  faire semblant
ouais tu sais si l'un de nous n'est pas d'
humeur nous n'allons pas ça ne va pas
nous n'allons pas le faire ouais parce que
ça ne semble pas authentique mais ce n'est pas
la force motrice  derrière notre
conduite polyamour  la force derrière notre polyamour est de
partager l'amour avec autant de personnes que notre
cœur le veut et de garder notre cœur
super ouvert
ouais y a-t-il de la jalousie avez-vous déjà eu des
sentiments désagréables oh ouais ouais oh nous
ne pouvons pas être méchants nous pouvons les battre oh oui
[  Musique]
euh je dirais que la
jalousie est notre plus grand professeur ouais mais
tu es très en colère contre tes professeurs oui
il y aura des moments où comme cassie
et mat aimeront rentrer à la maison après
quelque chose je serai comme si je me préparais pour aller au
lit je vais je  j'aimerai entrer dans la pièce
et ils seront comme dans un
moment
passionné  me rend jaloux mais je
devais régler ça comme si je ne me donnais pas
assez d'amour-propre je pensais
comme oh ils ne veulent pas faire ça avec
moi oh mais ils l'ont fait et ils l'étaient
et je ne faisais pas attention  parce que
j'étais tellement concentré sur comme
ils le font, ils le font ouais je
pense que ous  r la jalousie ne ressemble pas à tu
sais oh tu es je ne pouvais pas supporter que mon
partenaire embrasse quelqu'un d'autre comme
ça n'a jamais été
réel comme même la première fois que vous
avez
eu votre premier baiser j'ai dit à matt d'embrasser
dallas ouais j'étais comme  hé toi tu
veux descendre parce qu'on était comme
et j'étais comme pourquoi ne pas vous
embrasser alors
je pense que ce n'est pas vraiment là que réside une
grande partie de notre jalousie surtout
plus du tout comme peut-être un peu
au début  de notre relation mais
pas tellement du tout mais il y a
définitivement de la jalousie à propos de l'attention et du
temps passé mais euh quand il s'agit d'aimer
l'élément physique euh ou
juste de voir ça comme une étincelle entre
eux ça m'excite ça me rend heureux ça
me fait me sentir  accompli,
la partie la plus difficile est parfois de
me laisser être moi-même et de laisser Cassie être
elle-même à Dallas être elle-même et de les laisser s'avoir
ensemble et
m'avoir avec eux
ou comme moi avec la
relation individuelle avec laquelle
je pense avoir du mal  que
parfois plus comme une
chose d'ego que comme si c'était un
problème profondément enraciné comme je pense que ça
vient juste d'un manque de
je pense que c'est juste de l'insécurité
donc tu as appris le polyamour
à
travers le prisme de l'amour libre
ouais  exactement à travers l'objectif de
comme le hippie de Woodstock euh
ouais comme le mouvement d'amour libre et
c'était super intrigant
et mat nous a appris ouais parce que nous ne
connaissions pas le polyamour euh nous savions juste
que quelque chose se passait quelque chose de
bizarre se passait entre nous trois
euh et nous ne pouvions pas tout à fait
comprendre quoi mais matt était comme
si euh et si nous étions
polyamoureux et si nous étions dans une triade
et dallas et je
suis allé en ligne et j'ai immédiatement cherché
cela sur google et arpenté un peu ouais
définitivement définitivement arpenté  autour et
parlé et gratté nos mentons ou comme à
quoi cela pourrait-il ressembler si
cela tournait mal
que se passerait-il
euh mais finalement nous étions comme bien
nous sommes dedans ouais c'est déjà un peu
h  apparaissant alors voyons juste où cela
va et nous avons appris au fur et à mesure que nous
avancions la
chose qui a été la plus difficile pour moi est de
m'inquiéter de
blesser Dallas ou Matt parce
qu'ils me sont si dévoués mais à la fin
de la journée  nous sommes tous les trois
polyamoureux et c'est juste une
insécurité vraiment intense qui venait juste de
surgir euh quand je découvrais juste
comme oh je suis je suis gourmand je suis
fou je ne peux pas je suis je ne suis
pas honnête avec moi-même  à propos des
sentiments que je ressens pour l'un d'
eux et même si notre relation
a si bien commencé, je veux dire que j'ai
commencé à me demander ce que je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait quelque chose de mal avec
Dallas et ma relation, je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait un déficit ici  mais il doit y en
avoir parce que
chaque média dit que si vous
regardez en dehors de votre relation, il
y a quelque chose qui ne va pas euh
et donc même si au fond de moi
je savais qu'il n'y avait rien de mal, j'étais
toujours pris dans cette condition  ng est
toujours pris dans cette peur
qui vient de ces
limites normatives que nous imposons aux relations
et aux gens en général, que diriez-vous que cela
a été la partie la plus déroutante,
je pense que déterminer aussi quand des
couples comme vous deux doivent partir
et passer du temps seuls quand moi et Matt
avons besoin de passer du temps seuls avec moi et que vous avez besoin d'avoir du temps seul
et de comprendre comme les besoins de
chaque relation pour que nous
prospérions en tant que menace, nous avons comme des
accords sur les moments qui  nous aimons
vouloir passer du temps seuls avec chaque
partenaire, euh tu sais que cassie et matt ont
un rendez-vous de longue date le jeudi
, puis matt et moi une fois par semaine
cassie et moi nous avons toujours un rendez-vous de longue
date le dimanche
que nous appelons nos filles  rendez-vous et euh on se
parlera et on se reconnectera et le temps
passé en couple est très
important pour
ramener cette énergie à la
triade  moi et
très à l'aise avec notre féminité et
je pense que c'est ce qui nous a attirés l'un
vers l'autre, c'est que nous étions tous les deux
vraiment féminins et nous avions l'impression que
notre
connexion féminine notre connexion saphique
était euh forte mat aime vraiment
qu'il aime l'odeur du maquillage il
aime vraiment quand nous
jouons et sommes très féminines mais euh nous
le faisons définitivement pour nous nous maquillons définitivement et nous nous
habillons l'un pour l'
autre ouais et même depuis que je suis
adolescent c'était toujours quelque chose que
j'aime vraiment faire il a toujours été  très
en contact avec le côté féminin et je
dirais que cela nous attirait
absolument en tant que femmes queer
nous voulions définitivement un homme qui n'était pas
trop concentré ouais
surtout pas déconnecté de sa
féminité ouais je ne l'ai pas fait '  Je ne
veux pas être avec quelqu'un qui n'a pas eu l'impression que
nous avions l'impression de ne pas nous comprendre
que nous trouvons chez les autres, peu importe à quel point
ils peuvent sembler différents de nous
lorsque nous faisons cela, nous n'avons plus besoin d'être
différents en profondeur  pointez le
vieux dicton oeil pour oeil
il y a une loi plus profonde qui nous guide vers la
plénitude
une vérité d'être pour une vérité d'être
c'est beau c'est si beau
savez-vous combien de personnes nous ont demandé
pourquoi nous voudrions un homme  notre
relation euh je me suis posé la même
question pourquoi voudrais-je gérer ma
relation matt est de l'aide matt nous est
utile parce qu'il garde dallas
et je m'amuse ouais il garde ceux qui sont ennuyeux
aussi notre belle
relation ressemblait à nous
endormir  à 20 heures après le cours de yoga, ce qui est
une belle relation, mais pour nous, nous en avons
fait un an et nous étions
comme si les choses devenaient un peu grandes,
nous avons déjà 80 ans, nous sommes si vieux
euh si mat nous garde euh jeune et  frais
et intéressant
[Musique]
super travail et il est mignon
c'est super quand je m'entraîne parce que
j'ai un public tout le temps
j'ai des fans qui adorent tout le temps ouais
c'est un public quand il y a plus d'une
personne ouais ouais c'est comme ça c'est
quoi  y vous avez deux femmes c'est la seule
chose qui est la seule chose ouais c'est
le truc
quand vous dormez tous les trois dans le même
lit
est-ce que celui du milieu a une prise
pour brancher son téléphone
ils branchent tous les deux leur téléphone d'un côté
ouais  ouais
nous avons une multiprise ouais
nous utilisons une multiprise polyamoureuse
nous devons non seulement avoir plusieurs
chargeurs de téléphone mais nous avons aussi plusieurs
couvertures pour ne pas trop transpirer
ouais et c'est aussi très important
parce que euh vol de couverture je pense  est
plus euh important c'était une épidémie dans
la
couverture de polyamour voler ouais
[Musique]
comment gèrent-ils l'argent comment
divisez-vous les finances cassie et j'ai toujours
su qu'avoir pour nous au moins avoir
fusionné les finances était un très euh
très fort comme  indicateur de confiance l'un pour
l'autre
et puis quand matt est arrivé il était un
peu il était un peu hésitant au début
euh mais tu sais on était comme
bébé on va tout partager on
va partager notre vie ensemble comme ça
seulement  il est logique que nous allons aussi
partager nos finances ensemble
euh
et donc nous l'avons fait
euh ce qui est très utile pour ne pas tout avoir
sur les épaules d'une personne ou sur
le revenu d'une personne
[Musique]
que voulez-vous faire pour notre rendez-vous
bien
nous  nous devons faire du pop-corn
, euh,
c'est toujours la première étape
, puis nous
pourrions certainement
nous promener dans un quartier
ou quelque chose ouais,
vous pourriez avoir une intention légère,
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire, nous
allons probablement vous laver les yeux avant
votre enfant d'accord  ouais
je t'aime je
t'aime je t'aime je t'aime passe
un bon moment sois bon d'
accord je t'aime au revoir
peut-être pas au revoir je veux dire
j'en ai trois mais
tu as trois mains ouais d'accord
bonne chance
yay
euh pour notre rendez-vous aujourd'hui
nous devons définir l'intention d'
être dans le moment présent
paix paix tranquillité les uns avec les autres
et je pense que je ne fais qu'un
[Musique]
je pense que j'ai fait du pop-corn pour
chacune de nos poupées de rendez-vous ouais je
dirais que je pense que
ça remonte à  les traditions
c'est un g  Bonne tradition non ça se
passe
j'ai grandi en regardant beaucoup de feuilletons
avec ma mère
donc
j'aime vraiment regarder des trucs dramatiques
ouais et j'ai regardé beaucoup de vraies
femmes au foyer avec ma mère
[Musique]
bâtard
pourquoi as-tu les larmes aux yeux ouais
pourquoi pleures-tu pourquoi pleures-tu
elle a une raison de
pleurer  enfant comme des choses ici
euh ouais avoir une famille est vraiment
important je dirais que nous tous ouais vraiment
aimer réécrire nos histoires de famille et
créer comme un nouveau
c'est comme
super intégral je pense à notre
violet ouais le premier euh bébé que nous
voulons  ai-je envie de porter parce que
dallas est prédisposé à avoir des jumeaux ouais
je pense qu'ils vont tous les deux être
le parent préféré
et ensuite ils vont tous être comme oh
mon dieu maman est tellement un bâton dans la boue
qu'ils sont  Je vais être comme si maman criait toujours après
moi, maman est toujours  oui me disant de
faire mes corvées pour le travail
oui et je pense qu'ils vont être comme je
souhaite que tu puisses juste passer du temps avec
papa toute la journée ouais
maman comme
je ne sais pas ils seront comme pourquoi
maman veut toujours  ayez une
conversation émotionnelle et vous serez comme je
sais chéri ouais c'est juste la façon dont
les trucs idiots c'est juste la façon dont elle
est
ouais je suis désolé
nous l'aimons pour ça ne
nous aimons pas maman
je t'aime c'était surprenant  j'ai fermé
les yeux et j'ai eu un baiser et puis j'en
ai eu deux
c'est un peu ouais
c'est ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
je vous aime les gars
vous